empêché les hélicoptères de la
gendarmerie de filmer pendant les
manifestations
c'est l'objectif d'un lyonnais de 38 ans
il s'est pour cela rapprocher du comité
de surveillance des violences policières
de lyon lassé de se savoir filmer depuis
les airs lorsqu'ils participent à une
manifestation
il a ainsi décidé de lancer une
procédure juridique
accompagné de son avocat maître
lantheaume c'est une requête par un
manifestant qui a été introduite au
tribunal administratif de lyon contre la
préfecture du rhône par rapport au fait
que celle ci fait voler un hélicoptère
de la gendarmerie après lors de toutes
les manifestations que connaît la
métropole et il s'est interrogé sur le
cadre juridique dans lequel cet
hélicoptère intervenait une requête
légitime selon m lantheaume qui
s'interroge sur le cadre légal de cette
pratique
alors il n'y a pas d'égalité au fait que
le un hélicoptère survole une
manifestation en tout cas à priori là où
il ya un vrai problème par contre c'est
sur le fait que cet hélicoptère puisse
capter des images très précises
d'individus de citoyens qui sont en
train de manifester
et puis éventuellement enregistré ces
images
en tous cas de manière certaine les
transférer au poste de commandement et
les images est en visionner ensuite par
les services de police de gendarmerie et
les renseignements généraux ou que
sais-je
les inquiétudes réside notamment dans
l'utilisation qui pourrait être faite de
ces images ce qu'on comprend c'est qu'en
réalité un hélicoptère qui paraît si
haut et simplement en mesure de voir des
formes autres dont il peut clairement
vous identifier et avec la
reconnaissance faciale qui arrive on
sait pas forcément l'usagé qui sera fait
de l'image les manifestants qui pour
l'immense majorité n'ont rien à se
reprocher mais ne font que défilé dans
la rue selon le comité de surveillance
des violences policières de lyon la
capitale des gaules est la ville qui
compte le plus grand nombre d'heures de
vol en hélicoptère pour des missions de
police m lantheaume lui se montre
confiant quant à l'issue du litige et
espère avoir gain de cause dans quelques
mois